in a process which will require more and
more changes to the economy we began the
process by removing regulations by
opening up having done quite a lot of
that and having been able to push up the
rate of growth to nine percent we
anticipate that it will probably be
eight percent in this financial year
because of the state of the global
economy but is there more reform that
Government of India needs to undertake
yes there is more reform that we need to
undertake but that's the case with
everybody you know you you can always
move on to a more conducive economic
situation and among the areas of reform
that is already being discussed that is
on the anvil is a reform of the labor
laws is reform in the ownership of you
know in the in the banking sector in the
insurance sectors retail sale outlets we
are also in need of reform in the real
estate sector though that's the sector
which is booming so yes there are areas
in which government or when they will
have to continue to make changes to
improve the framework within which
entrepreneurs work but indian
entrepreneurs by a large respond very
positively when surveys are undertaken
on their expectations for the future and
are among the most optimistic the most
positive in the world